all right.
NOTE CONF
I'll be back in one minute.
All right?
NOTE CONF
Hello?
How we, uh it's even less of you.
NOTE CONF
My talk last week didn't work.
OK, how up?
NOTE CONF
Push on.
But I will remind everybody online because we're listening to
NOTE CONF
a recording.
Uh, that's no good, because your class is soon and
NOTE CONF
you're supposed to do the lecture before the class.
Um, I've been getting reports from my tutors that a
NOTE CONF
bunch of people are coming to class unprepared, not having
looked at the lectures.
NOTE CONF
That's not good enough.
You won't get through the course doing that because you
NOTE CONF
won't understand what's going on in the classes.
Um, class tutor does what they can, but there's only
NOTE CONF
so much they can do in the time available with,
uh, all of the other students needing attention as well.
NOTE CONF
And so it's their job to give treatment, uh, attention
to the students who have actually prepared, uh, before they
NOTE CONF
give their attention to the students who have not prepared
otherwise.
NOTE CONF
It's not fair on those other students.
OK, does anybody have any questions I'd like to ask
NOTE CONF
me before we get going.
There's something on the screen that probably someone should have
NOTE CONF
asked me now, Not your fault.
It's my fault.
NOTE CONF
I didn't have clear submission instructions for this first assessment
that's due on Sunday.
NOTE CONF
Um, if you're one of the four who've already submitted
don't worry.
NOTE CONF
We'll take your submission as it is and work out
how to run it.
NOTE CONF
But for everybody else, is these clear submission instructions.
Now, note that these instructions are on a oops.
NOTE CONF
They scroll down.
These instructions are on a standard, uh, Java run time.
NOTE CONF
So if you can import anything you want as long
as I'm just gonna get it.
NOTE CONF
If I run those Java commands on Java 12, I'll
add up that I want it to be in Java
NOTE CONF
12 there, just for clarity's sake.
Um, so I'm gonna show you exactly.
NOTE CONF
Uh, those didn't Those didn't, um, highlight the way I
wanted, but I'm gonna show you exactly what I mean
NOTE CONF
by those statements in the lecture today.
So there's no ambiguity.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna give you the example file of how to
do that.
NOTE CONF
Blah, blah, blah.
And this is the kind of stuff we would hope
NOTE CONF
that you can carry over from your second year units.
It doesn't always happen, so let's be explicit about exactly
NOTE CONF
how that's gonna happen.
But that's important here as well, because this week we're
NOTE CONF
starting to write our own Java code for our interpreter
that we'll be using through the whole semester.
NOTE CONF
So the machinery of how we run our Java code
and organise our Java code is important.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the scanner topic itself.
You know, it's if you've read it, you'll see it's
NOTE CONF
scanners.
A scanner.
NOTE CONF
I can give you the theory of them relatively quickly.
Um, and so maybe it's more on those those administrative
NOTE CONF
technical, uh, what we would call them Organisational details.
And we'll spend a bit of time today as well.
NOTE CONF
And so please ask lots of questions as we go.
Hopefully there'll be confusing things.
NOTE CONF
If you've got your own laptop, try out the same
thing on your laptop to see if anything's going wrong.
NOTE CONF
OK, so questions have been coming up as well as
I hoped about the semantics of this language.
NOTE CONF
So part of the what we do in this course
is we get into the nitty gritty, gritty details of
NOTE CONF
exactly what does each character mean in the programme I've
just written and how do I interpret them, and people
NOTE CONF
have been pulling out some inconsistencies in the description that
I wrote.
NOTE CONF
Um, and we've been clarifying those over on the other
thread.
NOTE CONF
Um, if I put a line through it, it's because
that's not the correct answer and that I've clarified something
NOTE CONF
and then I will have clarified it below with a
couple of examples.
NOTE CONF
So you can see there were a couple of errors
in there based on my original text description that have
NOTE CONF
been fixed.
Um, there's also an error above which I should fix,
NOTE CONF
um, where I need to say that I need to
repeat this line here.
NOTE CONF
If there is no D, nothing is put between each
repetition that belongs on the next line as well.
NOTE CONF
And extra clarification If there's no D.
Well, I don't do that right now, so I don't
NOTE CONF
forget.
So keep an eye on that forum thread.
NOTE CONF
But I'm gonna be S because forum threads can be
hard to follow along with, um, you should also be
NOTE CONF
able to come to the submission page and find a
an updated version where, uh, those those notes are clarified.
NOTE CONF
But of course, then you'll be going Oh, something's changed
and I didn't notice that something's changed.
NOTE CONF
So you need to keep an eye on the forums
telling you when new information is coming.
NOTE CONF
And then this is kind of a summary of the
way that new information goes.
NOTE CONF
Oh, OK, Any other questions on that one?
OK, it's a quick turnaround.
NOTE CONF
I did notice some people talking about the scanner on
the forums.
NOTE CONF
The java dot util dot scanner.
It's not a bad idea.
NOTE CONF
I went back and had a look at my solution.
I don't use java dot util dot scanner.
NOTE CONF
I read in off the, uh, command line using a
console red line.
NOTE CONF
But my solution wasn't necessarily quicker or easier than that.
Um, the thing that's curious is that that scanner word
NOTE CONF
is actually, it's similar, but not the same as the
scanner we're building here.
NOTE CONF
So we get into lots of subtleties, and, uh, I'm
tempted to be able to say explicitly to you exactly
NOTE CONF
how that scan is different to this scanner.
But I don't just wanna overload you with information.
NOTE CONF
Of course.
So, uh, I better keep an eye on this stream
NOTE CONF
because if you're all doing as you should, there should
be 100 80 people on the street.
NOTE CONF
I don't think we're gonna have many people on the
street, and I think I can see how many people
NOTE CONF
are on the stream directly.
Can I?
NOTE CONF
All right, we'll just take We'll leave the questions up.
Alright?
NOTE CONF
We got more foreign posts for me to answer.
I'm gonna do that here.
NOTE CONF
I'll do that this afternoon.
Good, Good.
NOTE CONF
All right, so our topic this week is scanning.
It's one chapter of the Crafting Interpreters book, and it's
NOTE CONF
a relatively gentle introduction.
Um, there's not a huge amount going on in the
NOTE CONF
scan, and there's not a huge amount of theory to
worry about, Although we do think about look ahead.
NOTE CONF
How far does a scan have to look ahead to
do its job?
NOTE CONF
That's our main piece of theory.
And then everything else is practical, and we're starting to
NOTE CONF
see the shape of our interpreter and the way that
we would generally write interpreters.
NOTE CONF
The key thing that a scanner does is it takes
character stream and turns it into a token stream.
NOTE CONF
So we introduced that token data type, and we do
the conversion from character stream into the token data type,
NOTE CONF
um so I.
I often think of compilers or interpreters as just a
NOTE CONF
series of translations from one data type to another, and
in this case we're going from stream of characters to
NOTE CONF
a stream of tokens.
Now, often those tokens kind of hold a string inside
NOTE CONF
them, but really have that have that explicitly in your
mind.
NOTE CONF
It was character after character.
Now it's token after token, but there is extra information
NOTE CONF
in each of those tokens, and each of these phases
these transitions from one type to another.
NOTE CONF
Well, that's at least early on there.
Are they adding information?
NOTE CONF
Well, they can't be adding information.
We can't create information out of nothing.
NOTE CONF
Um, but from the programmer's point of view, from the
human's point of view, it feels like we're adding information
NOTE CONF
because we're taking information that was implicit and hidden in
the original stream, and we're making explicit and obvious in
NOTE CONF
the next in the next type.
But yeah, that's a well, let's go through some of
NOTE CONF
this machinery, you know, just writing java programmes in this
context, because there's every chance that you've gotten to this
NOTE CONF
point without ever having to actually really work with the
Java compiler or VS code.
NOTE CONF
You might have been using J unit the entire time.
Um, so you just press a button and it goes
NOTE CONF
green, and you look good.
It's green.
NOTE CONF
I've done what I have to.
That's not what we're doing here.
NOTE CONF
Um, So I'm gonna make myself a main class that
does what I said.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna do I need you to do in the
assignment specification.
NOTE CONF
I've got a brand new VS code with nothing in
it.
NOTE CONF
And I'm gonna start from I'm actually using my local
version of Java here, not my docker version, but that
NOTE CONF
won't make any difference if you're using the docker here.
Um, I better open myself a file here, and I
NOTE CONF
better be in some kind of directory.
So where should I put this?
NOTE CONF
I might just go to downloads for this one.
No, that's not good.
NOTE CONF
Um, yeah.
Let's just clear out the download so we can open
NOTE CONF
it.
Oops.
NOTE CONF
So I just cleared that directory so we can have
a look at it.
NOTE CONF
It's only the right java code.
I mean, we could just make a main dot java
NOTE CONF
file, but that's that puts the Java file in this
default package, which I don't like, especially once.
NOTE CONF
We've got more than one versions of things going on.
So we really should put every Java code, every Java
NOTE CONF
class file into some package.
You know, people often do the com dot, dot, dot,
NOTE CONF
dot big long list, and then you've got a big
directory to get to it.
NOTE CONF
Trust me nuts.
So I just put a simple package name at the
NOTE CONF
top and chuck it in that package name.
And when a file is in A when a class
NOTE CONF
is in a package in Java, it has to go
into that directory in Java.
NOTE CONF
So I make myself a directory first sign one in
this case, and then inside that directory, I'm gonna put
NOTE CONF
my Java file.
But I'm thinking of my project as being one level
NOTE CONF
up, right?
I don't go inside assignment one to to do my
NOTE CONF
work.
I do my work outside that, and I keep my
NOTE CONF
source file in that in in that directory, one lower,
because Java forced me to.
NOTE CONF
So my mind is continuing to work at the top
level even though my codes further in, so I'm not
NOTE CONF
actually gonna open that assigns directory.
I'm gonna open my downloads directory in visual studio code.
NOTE CONF
Ok, well, I found some other junk in there that
was hidden.
NOTE CONF
Don't need any of that.
So let's delete it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so here's me opening a directory, and there's no
files in it, So visual studio code can't show me
NOTE CONF
anything.
But wherever you're keeping your work, you should open that
NOTE CONF
directory.
No, that's the F I can't find.
NOTE CONF
Wherever you're keeping your work, you should open that directory,
and you should have a a subdirectory for your package.
NOTE CONF
And it's in that package that I'm gonna put the
main Dutch out on now.
NOTE CONF
I've asked you to call it mean dot Java.
You can actually call it anything?
NOTE CONF
Uh, this makes things simpler.
Don't worry about the extension.
NOTE CONF
So you probably know what a basic Java class looks
like.
NOTE CONF
I'll quickly write one out.
I'm gonna get myself a chair.
NOTE CONF
So I'm not bending over awkwardly.
This may or may not look like the one you
NOTE CONF
need.
It's just something that we'll compile.
NOTE CONF
So because I've got it in that, um, directory, I've
got to put it in that package, and then it's
NOTE CONF
and that I just have to have the right class
name and then for to run, it has to have
NOTE CONF
a the main and whatever that does, I don't care.
OK, so I say that so hopefully that's a piece
NOTE CONF
of appropriate Java code.
But how do I compile it?
NOTE CONF
You might be used to pressing buttons or whatever, but
in this case, we're gonna compile it the hard way.
NOTE CONF
A third way is just to use the jav a
compiler and to give it the right information.
NOTE CONF
What I actually want is what I normally want is
to compile everything in a certain subdirectory.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and to do that, I just I tell it,
go find any of the Java files that are in
NOTE CONF
assign one and compile them.
Please.
NOTE CONF
Um, once I do that, it complains that I didn't
put a semicolon in, so it was definitely trying to
NOTE CONF
compile them.
Oh, yeah.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that line creates the class file up here,
which is we can't read that directly, but we know
NOTE CONF
that's the one that's run.
So how do I run that?
NOTE CONF
Well, in Java, I use the java to put on,
but I have to tell it exactly which class file
NOTE CONF
to run, so people often do this.
But that's not correct.
NOTE CONF
OK, so Java Java needs to be backup at the
top level, not part way down into your packages.
NOTE CONF
Backup at the top level.
It'll go searching in the right directories for you.
NOTE CONF
You just you have to tell it the class file
with its package, it's fully qualified package name, and then
NOTE CONF
it'll go into the directories to find it.
So you end up replacing that slash with a dot
NOTE CONF
because you're saying I wanna run the main class from
from the assignment One package and the Java goes, Oh,
NOTE CONF
that's gonna be an assignment.
One directory.
NOTE CONF
I'll go find that.
And the last thing is, you don't have to tell
NOTE CONF
it.
It's a class file.
NOTE CONF
You just tell it that you wanna run that thing
and it'll go looking in a class file for it.
NOTE CONF
I mean, you tell it that it'll load up that
class and run its main method, whatever that main method
NOTE CONF
is.
Sorry, I got Yeah.
NOTE CONF
And so just to show off a little bit more
of how this works if I put another file in
NOTE CONF
here called random dot Java.
So if it's in the same directory, it's gotta be
NOTE CONF
in the same package.
If it's in a file called random, it's gotta be
NOTE CONF
a public class random.
So let's have it print something else.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So what are those two steps that I did
before the JAS compile and the Java run do so
NOTE CONF
the J a just says, go find any Java file
in this directory and compile it.
NOTE CONF
And it did.
So it compiled both of those, um, And then when
NOTE CONF
I asked it to please run assignment one dot main
It went straight to the assignment.
NOTE CONF
One directory, then went to the main and ran that,
and random wasn't involved at all.
NOTE CONF
Just sat there, so I had two mains.
It doesn't matter.
NOTE CONF
Whatever I can have as many as I want, I
just tell it which one I'm running.
NOTE CONF
But if instead I asked it to do random, it
would do that one instead to the burger and pie.
NOTE CONF
Last of all is now this is another class that
I'm gonna use by one of my other ones.
NOTE CONF
It's gotta be in the same package.
This one's gonna have a just a help method.
NOTE CONF
Oh, so all that one does is is help make
it right.
NOTE CONF
So this doesn't have a man.
I can run the exact same line as before and
NOTE CONF
everything gets compiled.
No, Help it up.
NOTE CONF
Java didn't get compiled.
I did.
NOTE CONF
You wrong, you know.
Oh, thank you.
NOTE CONF
I hadn't saved it yet, so everything gets compiled.
Um, but again, it it doesn't actually get run.
NOTE CONF
It happens.
I could try and tell Java to try and run
NOTE CONF
it, please.
And it will say Oh, sure, I found the class,
NOTE CONF
but it doesn't have a main method, so that was
a bad idea.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and if I'm in here and say I use
that other other class which is in the same package,
NOTE CONF
so I don't have to do any imports.
So I've got to recompile because I just changed my
NOTE CONF
main and then I gotta rerun.
So it automatically did what I asked it to.
NOTE CONF
It automatically found the helper class in the right spot
and automatically called it.
NOTE CONF
So this is the general strategy for doing Java compilation
and what we recommend for you.
NOTE CONF
I recommend that you make yourself a package for each
of the different versions of locks you're gonna build along
NOTE CONF
the way.
And you just put everything related to that version just
NOTE CONF
in that package.
One level.
NOTE CONF
No fancy pants.
When you want to compile that package, you do J
NOTE CONF
a package star dot java.
And when you wanna run from that package, you do
NOTE CONF
java and then use the package name dot main.
And that way, if I've got multiple of these, if
NOTE CONF
I've got an assign one and assign two, assign three.
I'm really just doing the exact same thing each time
NOTE CONF
and just swapping out which directory or package I use.
So these are the instructions I asked you to do
NOTE CONF
for yours?
It should compile with this.
NOTE CONF
And it should, uh, run with this now.
I asked for a single file.
NOTE CONF
What that means is that you'll be submitting just a
Java file, so we will have to put it in
NOTE CONF
the assignment.
One directory to make everything work.
NOTE CONF
You're just submitting the file.
And as I said, if you've already submitted whatever will
NOTE CONF
make yours work because you've got it done nice and
early.
NOTE CONF
Um, if you resubmit from here on in, please follow
those instructions OK, Questions.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So we can do our own Java compilation.
NOTE CONF
We don't need to use build buttons anymore.
Right?
NOTE CONF
OK, let me show you how to use a bill
how to make a bill button work in VS code
NOTE CONF
just because I think that's interesting.
So Visco doesn't do as much stuff for you as
NOTE CONF
other editors.
You can import extensions which do a tonne of free
NOTE CONF
stuff, but we're avoiding all that in this course.
So you might have discovered by now the command palette
NOTE CONF
in VS code, which on this computer is command shift
P, I think F one.
NOTE CONF
Maybe if you've got your F keys automatically, that's right.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
F one.
I get used to command ship P, but I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
have to get out of it.
Because when I'm in the browser version that brings up
NOTE CONF
a private window instead of doing the command pallet.
Um, So the command pallet is where you can just
NOTE CONF
do any old action that, uh, VS code can find
for you.
NOTE CONF
And you notice that the most recently one I did
was run a task.
NOTE CONF
And so if I press that one, it'll try and
find tasks for me to run, and it's got a
NOTE CONF
bunch of built in ones.
Forget that.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna configure my own tasks to write and tell
you, uh, the E, the way I find best.
NOTE CONF
There's also a build a a matif B or something
for building things in VS code, which runs a special
NOTE CONF
task called a build task.
But I just stick with tasks.
NOTE CONF
Um, don't want any of those, but we'll just take
that one.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I got all this junk, so a task file
is put in a directory called dot VS code for
NOTE CONF
you.
And it's a task that Jason file and you just
NOTE CONF
fill it up with some information about the tasks you
wanna run, you give it a name.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna call this compile, uh, you normally leave type
a shell, and then in here, you just put exactly
NOTE CONF
what you would have put on the command line.
So once I've saved that in my task file, if
NOTE CONF
I run tasks that compile one appears on my list
and this is nice and fast because I can just
NOTE CONF
enter.
Enter.
NOTE CONF
Um uh, whatever.
Uh, it's asking me if it wants to scan the
NOTE CONF
output to try and automatically generate errors.
I'm gonna say no, don't worry about that.
NOTE CONF
And it ran the task for me and everything worked
just fine.
NOTE CONF
So if I just put an error in that, take
out one of my semicolons and ask it to compile
NOTE CONF
again, I get the compiler error.
Everything's working the way I want.
NOTE CONF
But I've got a nice keyboard shortcut.
It's just Mac shift, P Enter, enter and Recompile And
NOTE CONF
then I can go over to my task dot Jason
and I can add in a run task as well.
NOTE CONF
And so that one, if we recall, was jab a
sign one.
NOTE CONF
Well, let's do main again.
And now when I do command shift, P, run task,
NOTE CONF
there are two possibilities.
If I just press enter, I get the last one.
NOTE CONF
But I can go find the one I want and
run that and it actually gets run.
NOTE CONF
So this is a nice workflow where you control exactly
what happens at each step, and, uh, you can make
NOTE CONF
the different ones.
So the reason one reason I'm showing you this is
NOTE CONF
that's what I do in mine.
I've got a tonne of run and compile scripts for
NOTE CONF
all the different versions of lock locks that I've got
on my computer.
NOTE CONF
I've got compile and run scripts for the way I
generate the course material.
NOTE CONF
I got compile and scripts for everything.
So you're gonna see me going, Mac shift PN to
NOTE CONF
enter all the time.
I want you to know what's going on.
NOTE CONF
Right, Mac shift.
P is bringing up the command pallet.
NOTE CONF
If I'm if run task isn't the first one, I'm
probably typing run so that it becomes the first one.
NOTE CONF
Then I'm pressing enter and then I'm selecting which of
the tasks I want and inter runs it directly.in a
NOTE CONF
little terminal questions.
Nope.
NOTE CONF
Alright, right, Because we're about to start writing our own
locks.
NOTE CONF
Come on.
Crafting interpreters.
NOTE CONF
Oh, God.
So with the textbook as well, I want you to
NOTE CONF
remember every piece of code required is in the textbook.
You can copy and paste or retype from the textbook,
NOTE CONF
and we spoke about this last week.
Um, there's also a repository online, and you can just
NOTE CONF
download and it's all there.
Don't do that, right.
NOTE CONF
That's just my My analogy for that is trying to
run a marathon by getting a taxi.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but no.
You get to the end, but you haven't actually run
NOTE CONF
a marathon.
Download the source code.
NOTE CONF
Well, you get the source code, but you haven't actually
learned anything.
NOTE CONF
We're not We're not here to get a copy of
an interpreter.
NOTE CONF
We're here to learn how to write an interpreter.
Yeah, uh, but typing everything out line by line is
NOTE CONF
probably a bit much, so I encourage you.
Maybe just to grab big chunks.
NOTE CONF
And I think I said this before, Make sure you,
uh, make some small change so that yours has to
NOTE CONF
be a little bit different, and that'll force you to
go into each of the files and make those changes.
NOTE CONF
So my example is I'm not gonna call mine locks.
I'm gonna call it Matlock.
NOTE CONF
And then that will force me to make changes as
I go through.
NOTE CONF
And I'm also not gonna put it in the same
package called com crafting interpreter.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna put in a package called Matlock.
So I jump back over to my Java and I
NOTE CONF
hide away my assigned one cos that's not what we're
working on anymore.
NOTE CONF
And I make a new folder called Matlock it's gone
into the wrong directory.
NOTE CONF
So I move it to the right directory.
PS code is always doing that to me.
NOTE CONF
And so this is where I'm gonna put my files.
So this first file, which was called Locks, I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
make my own version of it.
But obviously it's gonna be called that look so far,
NOTE CONF
I've got Matlock dot Java, and now that's in the
package mat luck.
NOTE CONF
So I've gotta make sure that's the same And then
I can go back over and I can grab all
NOTE CONF
this now when I'm doing this myself, I'm reading all
these paragraphs beforehand, but you don't need me to read
NOTE CONF
out the paragraphs I'm gonna do summarising.
But all we've got here is a main.
NOTE CONF
I don't need to copy the first one.
What we've got here is a main that does the
NOTE CONF
basics of what we need.
But let's pull apart this man a little bit, so
NOTE CONF
it can't be called locks there.
It's gotta be called Matlock cos that's what I called
NOTE CONF
my file.
But the main can stay main.
NOTE CONF
Um, and he's making use of the arcs that come
in from Java.
NOTE CONF
If if you haven't used those before.
That's the command line arguments that have been sent in
NOTE CONF
when you did the Java line.
You can actually put more things after that and they'll
NOTE CONF
appear under Arg.
So mine's called Matlock.
NOTE CONF
So let's do that.
Let's call it Matlock.
NOTE CONF
So what this is saying is if the argument length
was bigger than one, you probably gave me too many
NOTE CONF
files.
So I'm gonna give you a little error message to
NOTE CONF
tell you that you gave me too many files and
I'm gonna exit with 64 which is he talks about
NOTE CONF
that in the text.
Otherwise, if you gave me an argument length of exactly
NOTE CONF
what I wanted, which was one file, I'm gonna run
that file.
NOTE CONF
If you gave me nothing, I'm gonna run an in
a rep report for you.
NOTE CONF
Now, you should have looked at this and go That
won't compiled.
NOTE CONF
Um Ah.
And another little point on VS code it.
NOTE CONF
These terminals down the bottom, you can have more than
one.
NOTE CONF
The terminal with the star here is the one that
the task runner sets up for me.
NOTE CONF
If I want to do things by hand, I've got
to jump back over to my own terminal.
NOTE CONF
So if I just try and compile this, it's gonna
work.
NOTE CONF
Because at that point I've copied a bit of code
that needs some more code before it's finished.
NOTE CONF
You'll say that in the textbook, but, like, I should
have scanned this and go, I don't have a run
NOTE CONF
file function, so obviously nothing's gonna happen.
I don't have a run prompt function, so obviously nothing's
NOTE CONF
gonna happen.
If it was only as far as I wanted to
NOTE CONF
go, I could just stub those out Is the phrase
we use?
NOTE CONF
So let me stub those out just for fun.
So one file has to take a single, which is
NOTE CONF
a string.
Why don't we just have it?
NOTE CONF
Print that and then run prompt Let's avoid takes no
arguments and just prints out something.
NOTE CONF
So this is called stabbing out the various parts that
aren't written yet.
NOTE CONF
Now, if I compile that, it quite get there.
Uh, so again, I'm in a static method here.
NOTE CONF
And so if I want to call other Java static
other methods, they have to be static methods as well.
NOTE CONF
No troubles for me.
I'm just dubbing them out, so I'll do that.
NOTE CONF
OK, now it's a problem.
And if I want to run this one, I know
NOTE CONF
that I want java Matlock dot Matlock is the class
that has my main in it, and there it is.
NOTE CONF
So I didn't pass in any commands, so it gave
me the run Prompt.
NOTE CONF
So And if I pass in, If I pretended to
pass in a file, then I would get the other
NOTE CONF
version.
So it's working the way I expect.
NOTE CONF
And this is how I want you to approach yours,
you know, put a bit of code in, experiment with
NOTE CONF
it, ST things out, make sure it's doing what you
want.
NOTE CONF
Don't just go copy paste one copy paste.
But you're not gonna know anything because you really do
NOTE CONF
need to know what's going on inside cos you're gonna
ask you, including in quizzes on code runner and stuff.
NOTE CONF
Adjust what it was already there to do something different.
I don't know yet.
NOTE CONF
Don't have a taste of that yet in class.
But once the assignment, the exam one practise quiz opens,
NOTE CONF
you'll get a taste of that because we do have
some, we say, um, extend the existing scanner class and
NOTE CONF
change its behaviour.
And so you really gotta actually know what the existing
NOTE CONF
scanner class is doing so that when you extend it,
it makes some sense.
NOTE CONF
And then I jump back over the text and I
go, OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
I'm good with that.
And I read your words and they make sense.
NOTE CONF
I might do one other thing, though.
I might go and put those into my tasks file.
NOTE CONF
So I had to compile and run for my original
one.
NOTE CONF
Let's make a compile and run for Matlock.
So I add them in.
NOTE CONF
I gotta put the comma always so this one might
be compiled, Matlock.
NOTE CONF
And that's just gonna be this line.
And this one might be run, Matlock.
NOTE CONF
And that's just gonna be I'm only making a few
small changes there, but now I've got in my run
NOTE CONF
tasks.
I've got these two as well.
NOTE CONF
So that compound it, I bet.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Notice that now that I'm in, um, tasks dot Jason,
um, I can't just automatically put another a file in
NOTE CONF
there.
There are bits.
NOTE CONF
There are tricks you can do with the tasks like
Jason.
NOTE CONF
I might leave those for you to discover or I
may have the answers in the class work.
NOTE CONF
I'm not 100% sure.
I can't remember exactly what goes in the class.
NOTE CONF
Work versus the practise versus the quizzes.
But we're down here so assignments and organizationally you can
NOTE CONF
see now I've got my work separated.
They're just in separate packages and I can easily compile
NOTE CONF
one without worrying about the other.
There can be errors in one without it affecting the
NOTE CONF
other.
Um, and as long as everything's OK in the matlab
NOTE CONF
directory, everything will compile.
This is all bad practise from, you know, what do
NOTE CONF
we call?
We're gonna call it, um, industry style programming.
NOTE CONF
You know, people will tell you you can't compile and
keep your class files in where your java files are.
NOTE CONF
You gotta put them in a build directory and then
you build your you to have a copy of this
NOTE CONF
and everything.
What we're trying to learn here, um, in this course
NOTE CONF
are these portable skills that apply everywhere in all the
languages, no matter what we're doing.
NOTE CONF
And so if you just add a layer of complexity
on top that might make things nicer in a larger
NOTE CONF
project, you're jamming yourself in the Java ecosystem, your skills
are stuck inside the Java ecosystem.
NOTE CONF
If I teach you, Maven doesn't teach you anything about
how you might compile and run Ruby code or compile
NOTE CONF
and run IO code.
So we go right back to basics and do things
NOTE CONF
ourselves because we want to have the portable skills that
we can take over more easily to other languages.
NOTE CONF
So please don't use maven.
Don't use run buttons if you can avoid it.
NOTE CONF
And VS code is a very portable ID E.
It works for all these.
NOTE CONF
We won't use VS code for all the languages we
learn necessarily.
NOTE CONF
But VS code.
All these eccentrics work in every language.
NOTE CONF
So then he goes ahead and shows us what a
run file's gonna look like and what a run prompt
NOTE CONF
is gonna look like.
So we're probably learning some new bits about Java here.
NOTE CONF
In fact, we probably learned a little bit about Java
right here, where it through an IO exception.
NOTE CONF
Um, our ears might pick up at this point because
none of this code here actually would throw an IO
NOTE CONF
exception.
So why is that there while it's there?
NOTE CONF
Because, uh, some of the meth.
Uh, some of the functions that we run can throw
NOTE CONF
IO.
And with exceptions, you know, if you run some code
NOTE CONF
that can throw an exception, you gotta throw one as
well.
NOTE CONF
So we can see here now where that actually happens,
because file read or bytes is the one that might
NOTE CONF
throw an IO exception, but so might, uh, buffered reader
input that can throw an IO exception too.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Uh, so we now see the real run file and
NOTE CONF
the real run prompt.
So again we are.
NOTE CONF
Ah, Well, I stopped those out, so I understand what's
going on.
NOTE CONF
I don't feel too bad about copy pasting that whole
thing.
NOTE CONF
So you notice.
There we go.
NOTE CONF
So he said his is private, whereas I said mine
is public.
NOTE CONF
I've actually got good reasons for that.
So I'm gonna go back to public.
NOTE CONF
And this is why I'm starting to make small changes
to what he does and in my decisions that are
NOTE CONF
just fine.
Does anything else in here have to change because of
NOTE CONF
my changes that I made so far?
No, that's ok.
NOTE CONF
Files has been imported.
Read all bikes is a standard library paths has been
NOTE CONF
imported.
Standard library.
NOTE CONF
This path is still the path that got sent in.
And then bytes and cha sets are all being imported
NOTE CONF
from the library.
So now I can see why they're being imported from
NOTE CONF
the library.
But I should notice there's a whole another function that
NOTE CONF
I haven't written yet, so I'm gonna have to stub
out, run and run seems to take in an entire
NOTE CONF
string.
Well, they all did, but, um, actual code.
NOTE CONF
So can you see the way?
I'm just kind of stabbing ahead of myself.
NOTE CONF
And the the logic of that is I'm understanding this
part well enough to know what it's using.
NOTE CONF
And I'm also predicting ahead what that function actually does
and that I that idea of consolidating information, predicting what
NOTE CONF
the next thing will be is by far the best
way to follow along with what the book's doing.
NOTE CONF
Because I'm then gonna read a bit further in the
book and get my expectations met or dashed learning.
NOTE CONF
That's I think, if you did come 1000 with me,
you know, I go on about this all the time.
NOTE CONF
The best way to learn programming is to set an
expectation and then to have it met or dashed because
NOTE CONF
that either reinforces your internal representation of what's going on
or it forces you to reassess your internal value right
NOTE CONF
of what's going on.
And unsurprisingly, um, run prompt is also gonna use that
NOTE CONF
same method.
OK, and with things like this, I don't necessarily need
NOTE CONF
to dig into it and go.
What exactly does an input stream reader system in do
NOTE CONF
if I get to the point of going, Oh, it's
pulling from system in, which is probably, like system out,
NOTE CONF
and then it's buffering it for whatever reason and reading
out of the buffer.
NOTE CONF
OK, cool.
Um, especially with Java, like a lot of other languages
NOTE CONF
wouldn't require you to have a buffered reader in between.
And so a bit of it's just working with the
NOTE CONF
API.
Um, but you should recognise, you know, are the inputs
NOTE CONF
coming from system in and I'm doing a red line
on it.
NOTE CONF
Whereas over here, the input was coming from a path
which is a file, OK, that's what I expect.
NOTE CONF
OK, so then this comes across, I've already got the
run method, so I'm OK with that, so I can
NOTE CONF
replace this one and remember that I want public instead
of private.
NOTE CONF
So I do that and the rest looks OK.
I think the run line is still there, so I
NOTE CONF
just try recompiling it.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So I complained that there's a public static run because
I didn't put the void in there.
NOTE CONF
You need a return type and that ran and then
I run it.
NOTE CONF
Ah, look.
And it's doing something new this time because I put
NOTE CONF
in the run prompt.
It's actually doing this loop here because we didn't put
NOTE CONF
in a file name, so it took us to run
prompt.
NOTE CONF
So it jumped into this loop so it print lines.
The thing two.
NOTE CONF
Oh, look, and it's repeating everything I say.
That's what I expect, right?
NOTE CONF
Because I printed out this little Chevron.
I read a line and then I ran whatever that
NOTE CONF
line was.
But running the line just means printing it back out
NOTE CONF
again.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
On we go.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So the machinery here goes on and on and on.
I can keep going step by steps with the machinery.
NOTE CONF
But I'd like you to do that.
I'm gonna talk a little bit more abstractly.
NOTE CONF
about it now.
I've demoed how to do it.
NOTE CONF
So when we get to actually running a line of
code instead of just echoing a line of code Um,
NOTE CONF
ultimately in our interpreter, that's gonna mean reading in the
line of code, interpreting what that means, doing a bunch
NOTE CONF
of conversions on it, doing some optimisations on it, executing
it and then showing the the the use of the
NOTE CONF
result.
And that's what we're trying to get you to do
NOTE CONF
with your first assignment, right?
In a very simple way.
NOTE CONF
Read it in, understand what it says.
Do those operations spit out the answer.
NOTE CONF
But we're only gonna build our scan.
We're building our interpreter out.
NOTE CONF
Little by little, we're just building the very first part
of it, which is the scanner.
NOTE CONF
So if we just build the scanner, the reading in
the processing and the reading out is going to be
NOTE CONF
changing it to a sequence of tokens and spitting out
the tokens.
NOTE CONF
And when we do the next phase, we will.
So so that's all the scanner has to do is
NOTE CONF
just reading the string.
Spit out the tokens and that's what that line does.
NOTE CONF
But some scanner class has just been introduced.
That hasn't been written yet.
NOTE CONF
That's our scanner class, not the Java Utah one.
Some scan tokens method is gonna be needed on it.
NOTE CONF
And it's gonna spit out a list of tokens.
So if the scanner doesn't exist yet, the token doesn't
NOTE CONF
exist yet.
The method doesn't exist yet.
NOTE CONF
That's our job in running a scanner.
And that's what the interface for a scanner should be.
NOTE CONF
Make a new scanner, pass it to some characters.
It'll send you back, uh, a list of tokens or
NOTE CONF
a vector of tokens or whatever collection of tokens you
want.
NOTE CONF
And they're just tokens.
Um, and then our scanners gonna say, Look, I I'm
NOTE CONF
also wanted to like running.
This means giving you back the answer I worked out.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna go through that list of tokens and
just spit each one of them out so you can
NOTE CONF
see that I worked out.
Now we've already got error handling in the Java sense
NOTE CONF
up here.
With our IO exceptions here, he's talking about error handling
NOTE CONF
within the locks sense because scanning any of these processes
we do might fail.
NOTE CONF
We might scan some.
We might try and scan something that's uns scannable.
NOTE CONF
That's unlikely, but we might try and pause something that's
unpassable.
NOTE CONF
That's much more likely.
We might try and execute something that's not executable.
NOTE CONF
And so we need to report back to the user.
Hey, something went wrong.
NOTE CONF
So we're building in the error handling here, and he's
doing that in his locks.
NOTE CONF
In his main method, he's just saying, Look, I've got
a a static error message he can call anytime and
NOTE CONF
it will just spit out an error for you and
everything else will stop.
NOTE CONF
OK, so you've got the machinery in there for that.
He also talks about how, in a real compiler, Um,
NOTE CONF
just spitting out a very basic error is not helpful.
You probably understand this.
NOTE CONF
At least you've got to be able to tell your
user where the error was because they're bringing in a
NOTE CONF
multi line file.
So as you do your error handling, you better have
NOTE CONF
a way of keeping track of where you are at
in the file.
NOTE CONF
So our scanner is gonna have to keep track of
exactly where it's at at every step.
NOTE CONF
It can't just do its job.
It has to do its job and go right now
NOTE CONF
I'm at Line five Character.
Six.
NOTE CONF
I'll try something now I'm at Line five Character.
Eight.
NOTE CONF
I'll try something now I'm at Line five.
Character.
NOTE CONF
12.
I'll try something so that if something stops, I can
NOTE CONF
go.
I've got an error and it was at Line five.
NOTE CONF
Character.
12.
NOTE CONF
So the way he's chosen to do that is that
in locks he has a general error thing.
NOTE CONF
And if the scanner pops an error in there, it'll
put in the the character in line.
NOTE CONF
So the scanner better keep track of the character in
line.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and then he says, you know, in his interactive
loop, if you get an error, it just breaks out.
NOTE CONF
OK, so what are these tokens?
Well, characters are characters.
NOTE CONF
You OK with that?
Tokens are a brand new type.
NOTE CONF
We've made up specific for this job.
Whenever you make up a brand new type in a
NOTE CONF
language like Java, you maybe create a class for that
time.
NOTE CONF
But class, using a class to make tokens is gonna
be a bit awkward.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we would have to have a class for token,
and then we'd have to subclass it for all the
NOTE CONF
different kinds of tokens.
Um, there is a need a way to do it,
NOTE CONF
which is using an enum.
An enum is Java's way of doing that.
NOTE CONF
Putting some a name at the top and having everything
else is just versions of that, so that's what he
NOTE CONF
chooses to do.
So another file is brought in called token type dot
NOTE CONF
java, to store the token type.
And whenever we do these kind of ens in in
NOTE CONF
Java, we tend to use capitalization and snake case.
Well, it's not snake case capitalization and underscores, uh, to
NOTE CONF
separate them from other things.
And what you need to do is you need to
NOTE CONF
see every type of token you might find as you're
going through the language, and often that's a character.
NOTE CONF
And you're just saying, Oh, this.
When I see a PRI a left prince's character, I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna start calling that a left parentheses token.
But other times it's multiple characters like maybe it's a
NOTE CONF
a keyword.
The keyword in in locks for V should turn into
NOTE CONF
one token, but a far token, Uh, and the keyword
for fun, which is how we introduce a function, should
NOTE CONF
turn into one keyword for fun.
So on and so forth identifiers are also single tokens.
NOTE CONF
So when I write V Fu equals that fu should
turn into a single token.
NOTE CONF
Um, so what kind of token should that be?
Well, I make it and identify a token.
NOTE CONF
So all the different kinds of tokens I represented here
and this comes from me interrogating my language specification to
NOTE CONF
find out all the types of tokens I might need.
But also, if I'm doing this myself, I'm probably getting
NOTE CONF
part way through my scanner and going, Oh, I need
a new token.
NOTE CONF
So I jump back over to token type and add
one, and he's got it all right here.
NOTE CONF
He's picked out all the different individual characters that might
appear and should be tokens by themselves.
NOTE CONF
He picked out all the two character ones that, well,
these are.
NOTE CONF
These are really the operators he's got here under one
or two characters.
NOTE CONF
Uh, then he's got literal, so a literal can either
be an identifier, a string or a number, and then
NOTE CONF
the keywords.
He's also added an end of file token, which is
NOTE CONF
optional.
You can always tell the end of file because It's
NOTE CONF
the end of the file, Uh, but he's chosen to
have a token that he'll emit at the very last
NOTE CONF
part of the file so that it's very clear there's
something that's not in here that you might have thought
NOTE CONF
of as a token.
No, it is that semicolon cool semicolon slash diet.
NOTE CONF
Is there anything you can think of that you saw
in the language that's not represented as a token?
NOTE CONF
Probably not, because every character should turn to to.
So now our job is just to scan through and
NOTE CONF
convert all those characters into a list of tokens.
Nice and easy.
NOTE CONF
You know, if we're just doing the one character ones,
that's super easy.
NOTE CONF
I just get a character.
Zero.
NOTE CONF
Is it a left parenthesis?
Then the answer is left parenthesis.
NOTE CONF
If it's a star, the answer is star.
I can maybe just make a switch statement or something,
NOTE CONF
but they're not all one character, so I need a
bit more machinery to make this work.
NOTE CONF
Now scanners can sometimes done just with Red X's, And
because Red X's are well known and powerful, you might
NOTE CONF
find a lot of scanners out there.
In fact, the Java tool scanner does this.
NOTE CONF
It just says, Give me a red jex and I'll
do what the red Jex does as a scanner, but
NOTE CONF
we're not.
We're doing this from scratch by hand so that we
NOTE CONF
get something more.
It ends up being more powerful, more flexible, but really
NOTE CONF
helps us understand the scanning process better.
Otherwise, we'd have to spend three weeks on red X
NOTE CONF
engines, and so instead of that, we're just writing our
own scanner for our particular purpose.
NOTE CONF
So, as I said, it's the now that's a different
token type, but you might have noticed that there's not
NOTE CONF
quite enough.
This is too restrictive to represent everything That was the
NOTE CONF
input stream.
EOMs don't take parameters.
NOTE CONF
So when I get to the especially for an enum
for an identifier string or a number, I've lost some
NOTE CONF
information.
The scanners just gonna say, Oh, I found an identifier.
NOTE CONF
But where do I write down that?
It was the identifier food.
NOTE CONF
I found a number, but where do I write down
that?
NOTE CONF
It was the number five, So his choice and it's
just a choice was to say, every time I emit
NOTE CONF
a token, I'm giving you a token type, and I'll
give you a little bit more information about it.
NOTE CONF
I think he gives you the string.
It originally came from the value that's in there and
NOTE CONF
maybe something else.
There are other choices for how you design that.
NOTE CONF
And I want you as you're going through this thinking
I would have designed that differently.
NOTE CONF
Ah, sure, and you could be right, depending on you
know, ultimately what your goal is and where the language
NOTE CONF
goes.
So he's created a whole another class, and he can't
NOTE CONF
do this with an enum because ens can't take parameters,
created a whole another class that's gonna store that extra
NOTE CONF
information as well as our token type.
So, really, tokens aren't an enum.
NOTE CONF
Tokens are these things, but in that is the enum
telling us what kind of token it is in.
NOTE CONF
That is the string that originally came from.
That's what they're calling the Lexi in.
NOTE CONF
There is the literal that I can convert it into
if it's a identifier or a number or a string,
NOTE CONF
and in there is which line it's on as well.
So I'm gonna keep track of which line I'm not
NOTE CONF
gonna keep track of exactly which character it appeared at.
I'm just gonna keep track of which line it appeared
NOTE CONF
at for reasons of simplicity.
Now, so I'm getting a list of all of these
NOTE CONF
things now I've got all the information.
In fact, I'm building information because I've got a string
NOTE CONF
came in and yeah, I could go look for all
the new lines to work out.
NOTE CONF
But this way, I'm gonna get a string of tokens,
And each token is gonna include what line it appeared
NOTE CONF
on Cool bit of extra information for me.
And I say the Lexi here, which where does the
NOTE CONF
word lexine come from?
Lex is lexical a string thing.
NOTE CONF
Lexine just means a string thing.
So he's chosen another word related to string, um, to
NOTE CONF
mean the original string that it came from.
So he's gonna keep both the string came from and
NOTE CONF
anything I converted it into because I decided I should,
because the token for the number one should be a
NOTE CONF
token that's got a token type number.
Then the lexine, which is the string one and then
NOTE CONF
the literal, which is the number one.
Whereas the token for the string one should be token
NOTE CONF
type of string the lexine, which is the string one,
literal, which is still the String one and then the
NOTE CONF
like.
OK, so there's a nice bit of theory here on
NOTE CONF
regular.
I mean, a regular expression is called a regular expression
NOTE CONF
because it's a regular language.
What's a regular language?
NOTE CONF
Uh, well, it's a rule where the grammar he just
says that a rule where the a language where the
NOTE CONF
rules of the grammar are simple enough to be classified
as a regular language and we skip over exactly what
NOTE CONF
a regular language is, which is OK, this is where
he's got one of his side points.
NOTE CONF
Um, but a regular language is a restricted set.
So in this case, in language is what we're talking
NOTE CONF
about.
Oh, we gotta get the words right.
NOTE CONF
Passing and scanning came in parallel, maybe not, um, but
from two fields, which is, uh, natural language processing and
NOTE CONF
programming languages.
And they converged at the point of regular languages.
NOTE CONF
So sometimes through the through the 20th century, philosophers in
particular, were trying to work out.
NOTE CONF
If you could formalise the way words were put together
Cos if they could formalise the way it works all
NOTE CONF
together into logics.
They could apply logic to written text or spoken text,
NOTE CONF
Um, and that was key to them, tracing out their
philosophical argument.
NOTE CONF
So the key, the most famous person you know on
that philosophical track is chomsky.
NOTE CONF
But I believe, um, who was that pommy guy?
It's gone now.
NOTE CONF
One of the other famous philosophers of the 20th century
was on that track as well.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and so they were inventing machinery that either the
computer science people were using or in parallel discovery.
NOTE CONF
And along that track you came to regular languages.
And what a regular language is is one where the
NOTE CONF
rules of how the language goes together are simple enough
that a machine can put it together and a machine
NOTE CONF
can pull it apart.
And it won't be surprising to you to discover that
NOTE CONF
it wasn't enough for natural language processing to stick to
regular languages.
NOTE CONF
But guess what?
For programming was just fine.
NOTE CONF
We can restrict ourselves to regular languages, and now the
computer can pull apart and put together the things we
NOTE CONF
write down.
And hopefully they're somewhat understandable to us, and then we
NOTE CONF
restrict ourselves even more to languages not just that are
regular but are fast for the computer to process and
NOTE CONF
easy for the computer to process.
And that's where we are here.
NOTE CONF
So now we get into the scanner class, which is
the one that has to go character by character and
NOTE CONF
make decisions.
But I just wanna stop and look at a character
NOTE CONF
and, uh, look at some locks code, which if I
was doing my reorganisation every year, I might put it
NOTE CONF
in another directory called locks and think for ourselves What?
Scanning a piece of lock code looks like.
NOTE CONF
Well, maybe if I do, OK, so this is locks
code.
NOTE CONF
I think you'll agree.
Unless I've made a mistake.
NOTE CONF
Actually, I can do it this way, too.
But then I maybe need those there.
NOTE CONF
So it's the same thing.
Um, this is lock code, right?
NOTE CONF
Tell me if I made an error because I got
too many languages in my head.
NOTE CONF
So if I was ah, let me do one more.
I wanna make the simplest line on the top.
NOTE CONF
This is also the code which is one plus two
by itself.
NOTE CONF
If I'm scanning this as I scan the top line
I can see a one and know immediately.
NOTE CONF
I've got a number and I maybe I can just
put that away as a number.
NOTE CONF
And then I see a space.
And I know I don't really care about spaces, so
NOTE CONF
I ignore it.
Then I see a plus, and I know immediately I
NOTE CONF
wanna I wanna emit a plus token.
So I've emitted a number token.
NOTE CONF
I've emitted emitted a plus token.
Then I emit a two token And then I made
NOTE CONF
a semicolon token.
And with all these, it's easy.
NOTE CONF
I'm just looking one character at a time, deciding which
ones they fit into.
NOTE CONF
Now I see a new line and I don't admit
anything.
NOTE CONF
But maybe internally, I track that I've just gone over
to line two, and then I see a P.
NOTE CONF
And what do I do?
Well, a P might be the start of an identifier.
NOTE CONF
It might be the start of a keyword.
I don't know yet, So I've got to look further
NOTE CONF
ahead to see the R, the I, the N, the
T.
NOTE CONF
And then I go, Oh, yeah, I can see that.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
You know, this is the start to be.
You can Yes, we're to be more mechanical than that.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, um, I've got to look at all five of
those characters before I realise I've got the keyword print
NOTE CONF
and I can ait keyword print.
What I'm trying to get at here is that the
NOTE CONF
scanner is gonna have to keep some internal state where
it's remembering what's going on.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna have to keep some state so that it
knows what line it's on.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna have to keep some state for the times
that it can't make a decision yet, and then, boom,
NOTE CONF
It can make the decision and admit the token.
And that's the work of a scale.
NOTE CONF
That's what we're doing.
And so then we'll get to the parentheses, which is
NOTE CONF
easy in the one than the two.
I mean, the one is a little bit not quite
NOTE CONF
as easy, because there could have been other numbers after
it.
NOTE CONF
And then when we get to Fu again, it's gonna
see an F.
NOTE CONF
We don't know if that's the fun keyword or an
identifier, so we have to keep reading to find out.
NOTE CONF
So what we're looking at is the machinery that does
that, but overall a scan token is just is gonna
NOTE CONF
be a wild loop that goes until it gets to
the end of the file.
NOTE CONF
It's going to catch up to where it's up.
Scan one token.
NOTE CONF
Go again.
Easy.
NOTE CONF
OK, cool.
And then when we finally get to the end, we'll
NOTE CONF
spit out an end of file token.
And this is our first example of seeing everything that
NOTE CONF
goes into one of these tokens.
Remember, they've got a token type.
NOTE CONF
They've got a lexie.
They've got a literal and they've got a line number.
NOTE CONF
So for the end of file token, there is no
Lexi.
NOTE CONF
There is no literal, but we know the line number
and we know the token type.
NOTE CONF
So scan tokens gonna be doing all the hard work.
And here's the internal state.
NOTE CONF
We've got to keep track of What character was this
token starting on?
NOTE CONF
What character am I currently looking at?
And what line am I currently on?
NOTE CONF
Because just like we saw with the print and the
food, the start might be lagging behind.
NOTE CONF
And I'm still heading off trying to find out more
information.
NOTE CONF
I gotta keep track of that start one as well
as which character I'm at OK, and this is the
NOTE CONF
help function.
So this is all the action is in this scan
NOTE CONF
token function, right?
Um he's using another function here called Advance.
NOTE CONF
And what advance Does is moves the scanner one step
along the string and tells you what character was at
NOTE CONF
that point.
So it does both those things.
NOTE CONF
The current is the point, the scanners looking at.
So it moves that one point along and then says,
NOTE CONF
What am I currently looking at?
I'll return that for you.
NOTE CONF
So if we do, char equals advance, we say Move
one along and tell me what character you saw and
NOTE CONF
it says shock.
I saw a character.
NOTE CONF
It was C.
And you go well, ok.
NOTE CONF
Was it a left parenthesis?
If it was, then please add a left for end.
NOTE CONF
If it was a right parentheses.
Please add a right for any of these single character
NOTE CONF
ones.
Just do it.
NOTE CONF
No.
Yeah, Let's do that.
NOTE CONF
Read the character that you heard.
Oh, yeah, it probably does Read the character.
NOTE CONF
And then when it's coming in and then with the
plus plus at the end.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Um So there better be this a token function.
NOTE CONF
So you see machinery is being built, but we can
just describe it as the omit the star, omit the
NOTE CONF
semi omit the whatever.
There's no extra information on these tokens, so it doesn't
NOTE CONF
go in there, but we'll have to fill those in
with something later.
NOTE CONF
Um, OK, so Well, what exactly would an ad token
look like?
NOTE CONF
If I didn't have an ad token when I wanted
to admit the left parentheses, I would emit a token
NOTE CONF
that was the left parenthesis that had the string of
the left parenthesis.
NOTE CONF
It had no for its literal, and it had the
current line number in its line slot.
NOTE CONF
And I'm gonna be doing that all the way down.
So you just write a function to do that?
NOTE CONF
The function to do that says, Oh, you better tell
me the token type.
NOTE CONF
And then the thing that goes into the Lexi slot
will be whatever I'm currently looking at the thing that
NOTE CONF
goes into the literal slot.
Well, in this case, it's always gonna be null, and
NOTE CONF
the thing that goes into the line slot is always
gonna be whatever the current line is.
NOTE CONF
So I'm just using my global variables of start and
current and line to fill in the details for the
NOTE CONF
Lex theme and the line.
And then I'm asking the user to please tell me
NOTE CONF
the token type and the literal cool, so not the
way I would drive this.
NOTE CONF
I would put a token left peren, so I start
start to drink that on every line.
NOTE CONF
But that's because I tend to be a more explicit
person, and that's a reminder of why it's important not
NOTE CONF
to just copy and paste this because what you're seeing
is you've done a really good job of building it
NOTE CONF
out.
But in some places you do hit the final product
NOTE CONF
instead of the thought process to get you there.
Don't fall into the trap of just going.
NOTE CONF
Oh, find a product Cool.
Whatever.
NOTE CONF
Get your head around the sauce process.
They've got you there.
NOTE CONF
Who's that?
I'm gonna ask you to watch your own.
NOTE CONF
OK, so his case statement here, he adds to the
case statement a default.
NOTE CONF
So at the moment, all he's dealing with are these
single character tokens.
NOTE CONF
And so if none of my single character tokens apply,
I'm gonna give an error Instead, it's just showing you
NOTE CONF
how to do an error.
You can tell what line the error occurred on, and
NOTE CONF
you can tell it the string to use for the
error.
NOTE CONF
And that goes back up to the locks class.
There was a static method on the locks class, so
NOTE CONF
that's fine.
You can call it directly.
NOTE CONF
But in fact we're gonna use this default place not
just for admitting errors.
NOTE CONF
It's for doing all the work to do with multi
character tins.
NOTE CONF
So here are some characters that required us to look
a bit further ahead to make our judgement.
NOTE CONF
I have none equal to sorry.
I have bang as a single possible token, which was
NOTE CONF
the negation.
But I also have bang equals as a possible token
NOTE CONF
which is not equal to it.
So when I see a thing, I don't know what
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna admit you.
So what he does here is, he says this match
NOTE CONF
function that it creates just looks one character ahead doesn't
consume it yet.
NOTE CONF
What does it we'll find out, looks one character ahead
to find out what the next character is and gives
NOTE CONF
you a true or a false.
So he says.
NOTE CONF
I've seen a bang look, one character ahead.
And if it's an equals, then I know I need
NOTE CONF
to admit a bang equal.
And if it's not, I know I just need to
NOTE CONF
admit the ban and in fact match actually consumes that
token.
NOTE CONF
If it's true, doesn't consume it.
If it's false, OK, when he sees the equals, he
NOTE CONF
goes, Oh, I don't know what I'm gonna see.
This could be an assignment operator, which is I've got
NOTE CONF
down as a token of called equal.
Or it could be the double equal bullying operator.
NOTE CONF
So I gotta look one ahead again.
And if it's true that I found another equal, then
NOTE CONF
please a me an equal, equal, otherwise just a minute
an equal and then less than the same trip everything.
NOTE CONF
And if you think about what that ad token did,
all that match has to do is just be careful
NOTE CONF
with the start and the current to make sure that
current goes ahead by one.
NOTE CONF
If we match and doesn't go ahead by one, if
we don't match and everything else will work out for
NOTE CONF
us, this is what I'm calling.
Look ahead.
NOTE CONF
Oh, look at one character to find out what decision
I'm making.
NOTE CONF
So there's the the match and it looks at the
next character.
NOTE CONF
And if it's expected, if it's not expected to return
false.
NOTE CONF
But if it is, it consumes that by updating current
and return strip.
NOTE CONF
So I, I mean this language could you around?
I'm consuming things.
NOTE CONF
I'm emitting things.
That's why he's got a picture of a crocodile eating
NOTE CONF
stuff and cropping it out The other end.
It's consuming things, and it's omitting things.
NOTE CONF
We're writing the, um, digestive track of the crocodile.
It's not a good thing to talk about with the
NOTE CONF
latest news.
OK, so why don't we do with longer leg seas?
NOTE CONF
So the first one that might be might be longer
is a comment.
NOTE CONF
We've gotta look ahead one to find out if we're
even in a comment cos it's a slash slash, But
NOTE CONF
once we see double slash, we know for sure in
a comment.
NOTE CONF
So there's just one look ahead and it still fits
inside the case statement.
NOTE CONF
But once we realise we're gonna come in, we then
just want to just keep consuming characters until we get
NOTE CONF
to a new line.
That peak is a bit like match, except it doesn't
NOTE CONF
bother about what it's looking at.
It just grabs it no matter what and keeps going.
NOTE CONF
Um And so as long as it's not hitting, hitting
a new line Oh, I think, yeah.
NOTE CONF
Then we'll keep pulling.
We'll we'll keep pulling your values in.
NOTE CONF
Um, but if we do get to the end of
the file and end of the line, we stop, we
NOTE CONF
stop pulling things in.
But again, just one look at it to the side.
NOTE CONF
We found the slash, and then off we go.
If that look had failed, we found one slash, but
NOTE CONF
not another.
We know we're returning the slash token.
NOTE CONF
So you end up with this tree, right?
You know, every character you see, I make a decision
NOTE CONF
of where to go.
And sometimes I have to backtrack from that decision.
NOTE CONF
Like I look at the slash, I gotta look ahead
a little bit to see if there's another slash.
NOTE CONF
Sometimes I have to backtrack and say No.
No, I.
NOTE CONF
I didn't mean that.
Um and then sometimes I have to say, Yeah, I
NOTE CONF
meant that.
And I'll keep going.
NOTE CONF
OK, The case statement also just says, Look, if I
hit one of these characters that I don't care about,
NOTE CONF
like spaces, tabs, carriage returns, new lines, whatever.
Just keep moving.
NOTE CONF
And this is actually I don't know if it's interesting
to you, but it was interesting to me to realise,
NOTE CONF
in most of the programming languages I write in, those
characters mean very little.
NOTE CONF
They really only mean something in one or two places,
mostly at the end of an identifier.
NOTE CONF
Um, and in reality, they're not actually signifying it.
It's a subtle thing.
NOTE CONF
The end of the identify is the fact that there's
not another letter, the fact that it's a space.
NOTE CONF
It's just kind of, uh, because the space could still
go away if there was any equals after it.
NOTE CONF
The only time I need the space is the two
things that look like identifiers might be next to each
NOTE CONF
other.
The idea that whitespace is actually kind of meaningless in
NOTE CONF
most languages is an interesting thing, uh, and allows us
just to S and it locks.
NOTE CONF
It mostly is.
We can just squish everything into a single line.
NOTE CONF
Certainly the new lines can go anytime we want character
first.
NOTE CONF
Ah, but when you get to the when you get
to a new line, don't just completely ignore it.
NOTE CONF
Update your internal state because you just jump to a
new line and you need that information.
NOTE CONF
But update that and then just keep moving.
Alright, so we can handle all of this now.
NOTE CONF
The next one we can handle in the case statement
is a string literal.
NOTE CONF
As soon as we see a double inverted comma, we
know we're processing a string, and this is where look
NOTE CONF
ahead is slightly different.
The the concept of look ahead is important.
NOTE CONF
I don't need any look ahead to get a string.
Once I see the semi the inverted comma, I know
NOTE CONF
I'm in a string.
Just like once I saw two characters I knew I
NOTE CONF
was in a comment, but I do consume for quite
a while after that and keep adding them into the
NOTE CONF
string until I hit the other inverted comma.
So it's not look ahead, because I know what to
NOTE CONF
do.
At every point I'm adding it into the current string
NOTE CONF
boom, and then when I see the inverted comma, I
know I'm done on the current string so cool I
NOTE CONF
can consume a whole string with no look ahead in
this case.
NOTE CONF
So this is the code that does that?
You know, I found the inverted comma.
NOTE CONF
So what do I do?
I keep looking ahead and consuming things until I get
NOTE CONF
to the end.
Just like before.
NOTE CONF
No problem.
And the difference is what you read or something, huh?
NOTE CONF
I got Oh, it's a bit further down.
I gotta spit out the actual token with comment.
NOTE CONF
I didn't spit anything out.
I just consumed it all.
NOTE CONF
But with this one once I've done all that stuff,
and I've got to have a case statement for when
NOTE CONF
I get to the end.
Um, once I've done all that, I do the admission
NOTE CONF
of the token.
And this time it does have a literal values.
NOTE CONF
And the literal value is exactly the same as the
lexine.
NOTE CONF
But with the inverter commas gone, so that's that.
And I put it in cool.
NOTE CONF
So still gonna look ahead.
But I'm pulling bigger things in.
NOTE CONF
You can see I'm obsessed about Look ahead, cos that's
our primary theoretical concept this week number literals are the
NOTE CONF
same.
Well, almost the same.
NOTE CONF
Once I see a digit I know I'm in number
land, so I don't need to look ahead.
NOTE CONF
But I do need to swap modes.
I swap into number mode and I start consuming numbers.
NOTE CONF
Now if I get to a decimal point, I'm good
to keep going because I know the decimal point might
NOTE CONF
be cut.
Start part of a number.
NOTE CONF
But if I get to a space or an equals
or anything, that's not a number or a decimal point.
NOTE CONF
I know to stop.
So you've got to help.
NOTE CONF
A function code is digit just to tell him whether
he's in a digit or not.
NOTE CONF
It's worth noting actually that this goes in the default
case.
NOTE CONF
So for now, we've just been doing case, case, case,
case, case, case, case, case.
NOTE CONF
We had this default case for errors, but case statements
can't have it in them.
NOTE CONF
So once we move from just being able to check
the character itself into having to make some judgement on
NOTE CONF
the character, we've got to move that logic into the
default case.
NOTE CONF
But it still feels like another part of the case,
Um, so if it's a digit that I found then
NOTE CONF
go into number mode and start processing the number.
Notice that I've got to start with a number.
NOTE CONF
I can't start with a dot and once we're in
number mode, we do have to look a little bit
NOTE CONF
ahead.
No, no, you don't.
NOTE CONF
You just do exactly what I said.
We just keep pulling in either digits or dots.
NOTE CONF
Um, until we get to the end and then we
spit out a number.
NOTE CONF
This time it does have a literal again.
And so we go find the literal We don't have
NOTE CONF
any things to strip off the front and the start
and then because we want to give it back as
NOTE CONF
a literal not just as another string we tell it,
we use, uh, Java's ability to turn the string into
NOTE CONF
a double and a double go in there.
Every number that we're pulling in here.
NOTE CONF
We're just treating as a double, whether it's in integer
or not.
NOTE CONF
Right.
So there's only really double here because we only really
NOTE CONF
had numbers.
Ah, that's right.
NOTE CONF
OK, so this is where the look at comes in
for numbers because his decision was that four dot and
NOTE CONF
nothing after it is not meaningful.
He only wants to accept it if it's 4.0.
NOTE CONF
So that means once you see a dot, you can't
know exactly what to do next.
NOTE CONF
You do have to look ahead one more to find
out if there's a digit, and he discusses the reasons
NOTE CONF
for wanting to do that way.
You can, of course, do the opposite if you want.
NOTE CONF
But these things mix together, and in this case, the
mixing together is with the method syntax.
NOTE CONF
Um, because that also uses dot at the end of
something, the end of identifier.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we've got a couple of two character keywords
that we might be able to do in exactly the
NOTE CONF
same way.
Or, for example, um, but that's not great, especially when
NOTE CONF
they we lose the uniqueness.
So we've got OS and ands and funds and bars.
NOTE CONF
We can tell them we got class and new, and
we can tell them from the first letter they're not
NOTE CONF
the same, but you don't want to restrict yourself to
that in a language you don't wanna make sure every
NOTE CONF
keyword starts with something different and they never repeat what's
going on.
NOTE CONF
So this isn't a great strategy for doing keywords, so
instead what he does.
NOTE CONF
As he says, as soon as I hit an alpha
numeric I, I know for sure I'm either doing an
NOTE CONF
identifier or a keyword.
Those are the only two things that can fit into
NOTE CONF
that category.
So I'm just gonna consume it like an identifier to
NOTE CONF
suck it up.
I can identify it, and you can guess what that's
NOTE CONF
gonna look like.
That's doesn't need any look ahead.
NOTE CONF
But it's just gonna chomp a bunch of stuff until
it finds something that's not, uh, an alpha numeric because
NOTE CONF
you can't have a in this one.
I don't think you can have numbers in your variable
NOTE CONF
in your identifiers, and you kind of have dots and
pluses and stars in your identifiers.
NOTE CONF
So if you see them, you've finished your identifier and
you go back to in the loop again.
NOTE CONF
But he's com that that's completely wiping our keywords, which
sounds bad, but he just does one extra step, he
NOTE CONF
says.
Once you've found you identifier, go look up this hash.
NOTE CONF
And if the identifier is in this hash, it wasn't
really an identifier.
NOTE CONF
It was a keyword.
And so spit out the token for that keyword.
NOTE CONF
Please So the hash has got the string that you
would have found or the identifier you would have found.
NOTE CONF
And then the the token.
You should actually admit for that instead of identifier.
NOTE CONF
So he pulls in like an identifier says, I'm gonna
check to see if it was a keyword.
NOTE CONF
If it's not a keyword, I'll spit it out like
an identifier.
NOTE CONF
If it is, I'll spit it out like a keyword.
So OK, no look ahead.
NOTE CONF
Required here inside the machinery to do what are the
things that might have needed to look ahead?
NOTE CONF
Cool.
We're done.
NOTE CONF
That's it.
But there's there's quite a bit of machinery in there,
NOTE CONF
so we might do a little bit of playing around
with the machinery that's in there now.
NOTE CONF
OK, uh, but do we have questions?
Is this a nice simple algorithm that we just spent
NOTE CONF
an hour talking about?
Um, there's a bit of a this.
NOTE CONF
This class is interesting in the sense that we get
to spend a lot of time on a fairly simple
NOTE CONF
algorithm and implement it completely with warts and all.
Uh, and that doesn't happen very often in your undergraduate.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, I'm encouraging you not to skip over the
warts and all, because they are important.
NOTE CONF
I mean, the devil's always in the detail.
We actually get to touch the detail here and play
NOTE CONF
with you.
OK, so let's look at the scanner that came in.
NOTE CONF
I've got it all loaded up so you don't have
to watch me copy and paste like I'm encouraging you
NOTE CONF
to do.
Um, he's got some design notes here, which are really
NOTE CONF
interesting, actually.
Maybe I'll talk about them first.
NOTE CONF
When you design a programming language, the syntax of a
programming language, you've got the user in mind.
NOTE CONF
Obviously, you want something that the user can understand, but
you've also got the scanner in mind.
NOTE CONF
If it can't be scanned, it's no good, and some
people over the years people will come up with lots
NOTE CONF
of different tricks.
You'll have seen them and you'll see more of them.
NOTE CONF
He's talking specifically here about semi Simons are horrible, right?
I keep leaving them out, he told me.
NOTE CONF
Just do it earlier today and they always just go
at the end of the line.
NOTE CONF
So they're a prime candidate.
You're like surely I can get rid of semicolons.
NOTE CONF
What if I just made a new line, always being
a semicolon, and off I go, uh, but when you're
NOTE CONF
designing a language, you've got to think about how that
interacts with everything else.
NOTE CONF
So one language where they did try and make semicolons
go away.
NOTE CONF
Well, there's two ways to make semicolons go away.
One is to replace them with new lines.
NOTE CONF
The other is to guess where they belong, and you
put them in as if they were there, so that
NOTE CONF
the user could put them in if they wanted.
But if they leave them out, you'll guess the first
NOTE CONF
one says no, you're not allowed to put semicolons in.
I'll complain.
NOTE CONF
The second one says, Sure, put them in if you
want them.
NOTE CONF
But if you don't put them in, I can probably
guess where you meant the semicolon to go.
NOTE CONF
So Python chooses the first one, And the downside of
that is that new lines, meaning a, uh, new lines,
NOTE CONF
meaning a semicolon is easy enough.
But new lines meaning a new block of code is
NOTE CONF
more difficult, and all of a sudden spaces have to
start meaning something, so you can indent and then out.
NOTE CONF
Ding has to mean something, and there are various corners.
You get into it with that that lots of people
NOTE CONF
don't like.
Uh, JavaScript chose the second option, which was, We'll, we'll
NOTE CONF
you get back to the Curly Brace is in.
But we'll try and guess where the semicolons are.
NOTE CONF
And that's called implicit semicolons.
Um, so you'll treat a new line as a statement
NOTE CONF
Terminator.
When it makes sense to do so well, most statements
NOTE CONF
are on their lines.
Sometimes you need to spread a single statement across multiple
NOTE CONF
lines, and that's where things get nasty and I.
I put single statements over multiple lines all the time.
NOTE CONF
Personally, I do it a lot, a lot more than
most, so it seems like a lay down was there,
NOTE CONF
as in an obvious win.
But it's not.
NOTE CONF
So you go through a few of the options lure
completely, ignores new lines but has a really carefully controlled
NOTE CONF
grammar, so it doesn't make any difference.
Uh, he he's been so smart about the grammar that
NOTE CONF
you don't need a new loan or a semicolon to
tell when one statement finishes and another one begins, Uh,
NOTE CONF
but again, that has its own downsides.
Go handles new lines in the scanner.
NOTE CONF
If a new line appears following one of a handful
of token types that are known to end a statement,
NOTE CONF
a new line is treated like a semicolon.
Otherwise it's ignored.
NOTE CONF
So that's a kind of implicit semicolon idea.
Python treats all new lines as significant unless an explicit
NOTE CONF
B backslash here's a good point.
This all works really well because Python is a highly
NOTE CONF
statement oriented language.
Did we get to talk about expression oriented versus statement
NOTE CONF
oriented languages?
I think we did that last week, he said.
NOTE CONF
And he said, I'll do it again.
Um, in You know, the difference between an expression is
NOTE CONF
that it returns a value and a statement just does
a thing you're used to language is the mixing.
NOTE CONF
Statements and expressions include things that are both statements and
expressions.
NOTE CONF
It's a fluid thing.
A function call is a statement and an expression in
NOTE CONF
Java.
Other languages say no.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna make sure everything's an expression.
It always returns something.
NOTE CONF
Now those ones expressions have to also be statements.
What Python does is it goes extremely the other way
NOTE CONF
and and really doubles down on statements as being the
main structure of the language and very few things are
NOTE CONF
expressions.
I didn't understand that until I came to understand that
NOTE CONF
Python is a scripting language for C, in which case
it makes a lot more sense.
NOTE CONF
Uh, really Just scripting statement after statement after statement.
Um, so what he's saying here is that the the
NOTE CONF
lack of semicolons works great or works relatively well in
Python because it's so statement oriented.
NOTE CONF
But as a python programmer, there are so many other
bad things that come with being statement oriented.
NOTE CONF
It drives me crazy.
Um, you can never There's no free lunches here.
NOTE CONF
Everything comes with a trade off cos everything's, uh, intertwined.
JavaScript's automatic semi colon is odd, But let me tell
NOTE CONF
you, just like a lot of things in javascript, Damien
will disagree, But he can be quiet cos I'm lecturing
NOTE CONF
just like a lot of things.
Just like a lot of things in javascript.
NOTE CONF
It just works so often that OK, the weird.
I can ignore the weirdness and just get on with
NOTE CONF
it.
Um, semicolon insertion.
NOTE CONF
Uh, variable hoistings caught me out in javascript, but semicolon
insertion never has.
NOTE CONF
Okey dokey, but these this is a little taste of
the language design questions that come up, and the reason
NOTE CONF
there are so many different languages to learn is because
the designers have just picked different spots in this design
NOTE CONF
space and then the choices they've made, just like with
anything that's subjective.
NOTE CONF
Um, we all have different opinions on what's good looking,
uh, appealing.
NOTE CONF
You go to an art gallery.
You like one thing.
NOTE CONF
I like another thing.
It's the same in programming, right?
NOTE CONF
You.
If you share the tastes of the language designer, you
NOTE CONF
prefer their language.
It's just a subjective thing.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I like to think of that taste as
being a little bit more than just what you might
NOTE CONF
think of as taste.
It's more about Does your thought processes line up with
NOTE CONF
the language designers thought processes?
Um, and because there's so many different ways to think,
NOTE CONF
we've got so many different ways to do languages.
So there's some examples here of things we might do
NOTE CONF
with a scanner.
Should we try one of them?
NOTE CONF
Well, the non regular we cha.
We talked a little bit about that, but maybe we
NOTE CONF
won't chase up on that one.
We probably won't get to finish it.
NOTE CONF
But let's try and think about what we might do
for block comments.
NOTE CONF
OK, so to do all this, I've gotta jump over
to another visual studio and I've got to open.
NOTE CONF
So come 3001 and it's a dev container.
So it's doing that and then I close all Where's
NOTE CONF
all the clothes?
Where's the clothes?
NOTE CONF
All, uh, do I click here for close?
All that?
NOTE CONF
All OK, now you can see a bit more about
the way my files are organised.
NOTE CONF
I got a lot more going on in come 3000
than just my Java code.
NOTE CONF
So I've got a directory for the Java code and
the lock code and my Matlock code under the Java
NOTE CONF
code.
You can see I've got, uh, coffee, one I'm playing
NOTE CONF
with.
I've got the crafting interpreters one right here.
NOTE CONF
I've got one that I've been playing with, and right
now, what I wanna do is I wanna make some
NOTE CONF
changes to the crafting interpreters one so that we can
do some experimenting with it.
NOTE CONF
So here's how I'm going to go about doing that.
I am going to MKD Java, and I'm gonna call
NOTE CONF
it block coms, cos we're doing block comments.
So I just made a new directory called Block Coms.
NOTE CONF
And then I'm gonna CP everything from the crafting interpreters
side over.
NOTE CONF
So I want this part of the directory.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna copy every file I've got in there into
block coms.
NOTE CONF
So now I've just got this is actually his whole
compiler, not just the scanner, but I've got a copy
NOTE CONF
of the entire scanner, but the entire compiler that's separate
from the original one, it's not gonna compile because all
NOTE CONF
these package lines are wrong.
So I'm gonna control shift.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna do a a package com dot crafting and
Deborah does dot locks one too many, Ms.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna search for all of those only in
my directory.
NOTE CONF
Um, which is why is it only pulling one?
There it is.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna search for that.
Only in the ones I copied over.
NOTE CONF
And I'm gonna replace that with package block homes.
So it's in the right package.
NOTE CONF
Name?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Do you want in there?
I think I did.
NOTE CONF
Just, uh yeah, just one there.
What comes?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So then I'll try to make that replace all 17
NOTE CONF
sounds about right because there's 17 files and so it's
done it.
NOTE CONF
And now down here, I'm gonna try out compiling it
to see.
NOTE CONF
So that's J Axe.
I know I need to go into the Java directory.
NOTE CONF
That's my base in this case.
And then it's J back.
NOTE CONF
What star dot Java, and it's got a pile of
errors.
NOTE CONF
So he must have made a mistake somewhere.
Oh, there's a bunch of other places where com dot
NOTE CONF
crafting interpreters is being used that I haven't converted.
OK, so let's make all those conversions happen.
NOTE CONF
Let's try this.
How many are you gonna find?
NOTE CONF
Just the one and one We'll replace it.
I'll try to compile again.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
I broke some weirdness over there.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I have to say I left that in.
So now I gotta do this.
NOTE CONF
Replaced with is that I made a mistake in my
replacement.
NOTE CONF
Are you gonna find any?
No, There is better like that.
NOTE CONF
I'm try compiling again.
No.
NOTE CONF
Still in here side.
Let's go back and look at this token type.
NOTE CONF
There must be something more going on in token type,
that's all.
NOTE CONF
OK, so it's pasa 486 I.
I sh It's a bit.
NOTE CONF
It's a bit of a annoying that I'm having to
make this many changes.
NOTE CONF
I was hoping I could just do it a bit
more quickly, but I would I do want to have
NOTE CONF
a separate copy of all this.
Um, I don't just wanna use I don't want to
NOTE CONF
make adjustments to the original one.
So this is the kind of the process I have
NOTE CONF
to go through to make those kinds of adjustments.
Maybe if I did a bit more idea work, I
NOTE CONF
could, um, make it a bit easier.
Let's go find this pasa 486.
NOTE CONF
So that's he's struggling.
All right, We'll go to the hard way.
NOTE CONF
Ah, there it is.
Oh, it's the static import.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
You need a static input.
NOTE CONF
So that one you'll see that when we get to
it.
NOTE CONF
That's the block.
Coms there.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So that was one extra thing I would have had
NOTE CONF
to change, and they'll probably be one of the scanners.
Well, no, we're good.
NOTE CONF
OK, Finally.
So now I've got my own version I can play
NOTE CONF
with here where I've got his original scanner somewhere here,
under scanner.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and I can make changes to it.
That is when I pulled in his code as well,
NOTE CONF
which I don't encourage you ever to do.
You might have.
NOTE CONF
You might have copied and pasted block by block to
have your own.
NOTE CONF
But, um, he's got a bunch of these things which
he uses to, um, build his textbook.
NOTE CONF
So some of the lines that are in here are
comments that don't belong in the final programme.
NOTE CONF
Some of them, he says.
This is where I'm talking about two char tokens, so
NOTE CONF
that's the bit will get copied over the textbook.
So that's another reason not to copy his directly.
NOTE CONF
I hear the whole section that appears.
We saw that we saw that in his discussion of
NOTE CONF
scandals, but it doesn't belong in his final version.
So he commented it out, blah, blah, blah.
NOTE CONF
So maybe I should make another version where I'm keeping
up with the book in the way I expect you
NOTE CONF
to keep up with the book that I can, um,
copy them across each time.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the other thing I need to do when I'm
working on his is I gotta go back and change
NOTE CONF
the main one cos we only want to use the
scanner.
NOTE CONF
This main one is for the final project.
So run that that line of code we had before
NOTE CONF
this run one.
There's a heap of stuff.
NOTE CONF
I don't wanna do it.
This is all the future stuff.
NOTE CONF
So I come in all that out and un comment
the one we actually want to do.
NOTE CONF
So hopefully now we've got a scanner and I try
running that which is block coms dot locks in this
NOTE CONF
case because I didn't rename it and it brings it
up and I go hi there and does it.
NOTE CONF
So here's what.
Well, we haven't actually seen this yet, so maybe this
NOTE CONF
is a good thing to do as well.
First, here's just a scanner running.
NOTE CONF
It got in.
That's not actually valid locks that I put in there.
NOTE CONF
Hi there, but it's valid enough for the scanner cos
we haven't made it to parsing yet.
NOTE CONF
Um, so because I just call blocks by itself, I
get the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
I put some possible code in, and the scanner scans
it as an identifier high and an identifier there.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
So let's try some actual looks.
NOTE CONF
Alright, I've missed the semicolon, which the parser will catch
up.
NOTE CONF
Um, but the scanner doesn't look for S for that.
So it it interpreted it.
NOTE CONF
It's got the keyword file and identifier X and equals
token and number token.
NOTE CONF
Very cool.
And and a file.
NOTE CONF
So if I had done that correctly, then I would
get the exact same scan, but with the extra semicolon
NOTE CONF
token appearing, which is what the pause is ultimately gonna
need further down the track.
NOTE CONF
So how might we go about doing?
I'm not actually going to be able to test block
NOTE CONF
comments here, cos I've only got one line.
Um, put a comment in.
NOTE CONF
What do I get?
Here you go.
NOTE CONF
When I scan a comment, I just get the end
of file because that's exactly what the scanner is designed
NOTE CONF
to do.
It's designed to spit out anything else, uh, ignore anything
NOTE CONF
else.
So this is the last thing today, so we'll obviously
NOTE CONF
finish up a bit early, even compared to a two
hour block.
NOTE CONF
We'll finish up early.
Um, but it's the last thing that we're gonna do
NOTE CONF
today.
Let's map out what we might do for block comments.
NOTE CONF
So the spot for comments is where we see a
slash in our scanner.
NOTE CONF
So here's our scan token one which was doing the
switch dum dum dum dum dum, and we saw the
NOTE CONF
one where it found a slash and it said, Well,
if the next thing's a slash, I know I'm doing
NOTE CONF
a comment that goes to the end of the line.
Otherwise, I'm just giving a slash cos that's an actual
NOTE CONF
proper token as well.
But there's a third alternative here, which is that if
NOTE CONF
it's slash star, I've just hit a multi line comment.
So I need to put another if in here for
NOTE CONF
that, right?
I need to do something like if you saw star
NOTE CONF
after you saw slash then do multi line comment else
do slash.
NOTE CONF
And then I got to think to myself, What does
multi line comment look like?
NOTE CONF
That's where things get slightly tricky.
When we were when we had a single line comment,
NOTE CONF
we knew exactly when to stop by looking at a
single token.
NOTE CONF
If that if that single character, if that character was
a new line or the end of the file, we
NOTE CONF
knew that the comment had stopped in this case a
new line is not gonna stop the comment.
NOTE CONF
Uh, end of file is still gonna stop to comment,
but the other thing that's gonna stop the comment is
NOTE CONF
two characters, a star and a forward slash So it's
a little bit trickier for us.
NOTE CONF
What are you gonna look like this wild peak?
So let's start from that.
NOTE CONF
So when peak is not equal to new line, we
kept going, and when it was at new end, we
NOTE CONF
kept going.
So maybe what we wanna do is we wanna say,
NOTE CONF
while Peak is not equal to star and there's another
peak in here, right?
NOTE CONF
All right.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Look, there's two Peaks.
We didn't talk about it when we went through, but
NOTE CONF
if you read the book, you will.
There's a place where he needs to pick not just
NOTE CONF
on the next character, but the character after that as
well.
NOTE CONF
So he creates a peak which just goes one character
ahead, and then he creates a peak that goes two
NOTE CONF
characters ahead so we can use that.
That's gonna do the job for us.
NOTE CONF
So as long as long as Peak is not equal
to star the next, that's where I've got to get
NOTE CONF
my not equals to right, because I don't think I've
quite got it right here.
NOTE CONF
Right.
What the heck?
NOTE CONF
What have I done wrong?
The colouring is not working.
NOTE CONF
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
Thanks slash Slash.
So I kinda wanna say something.
NOTE CONF
Like while Peak is not equal, star and peak next
is not equal to the F, the backslash, and I'm
NOTE CONF
not at the end advance Once I hit one of
those conditions.
NOTE CONF
Stop.
Yeah, but it's backslash because we're ending because csar come
NOTE CONF
in.
Yeah, Yeah.
NOTE CONF
This isn't quite right, because this is actually gonna stop
as soon as it sees one star or it sees
NOTE CONF
one slash.
So I've got to adjust what's going on here.
NOTE CONF
Um, but my brain's not working for that after a
whole lecture.
NOTE CONF
And so I'll leave logic alone instead of getting it
wrong 12 times.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the key here is showing you, you know, where
you go into the scanner to make this change, thinking
NOTE CONF
about how far you've got to look ahead and then
knowing which of the scanner methods are gonna get you
NOTE CONF
that look ahead.
Uh, so maybe I'll finish this one off.
NOTE CONF
Um so that I've actually just got the solution to
chuck up some way when my brain is cleared and
NOTE CONF
I can think properly about that cos we need it.
We need to stop when Peak and Pete next both
NOTE CONF
go True.
So I actually need this.
NOTE CONF
I'm pretty sure this is what I need, as long
as it's not true that both of those are true.
NOTE CONF
And it's not true that I'm at the end.
Keep going.
NOTE CONF
All right.
So I might leave it there.
NOTE CONF
Well, I will leave it there.
The questions, comments.
NOTE CONF
Have fun with that first assessment as hopefully you can
see.
NOTE CONF
Now it's a very valuable activity for the activity we're
doing here, but it is separate.
NOTE CONF
I don't want to bump steer you by sending you
too much down the ah, I better just write a
NOTE CONF
scanner like the book tells me to.
The scanning unit is way simpler.
NOTE CONF
Um and it doesn't require the scanning machinery we've got
here.
NOTE CONF
You can just do it.
Uh, but the concepts that we've covered here might enlighten
NOTE CONF
some of the things you've been worrying about as you
go through it.
NOTE CONF
And also, uh, yeah, we agree.
Also That's right.
NOTE CONF
So I was about to perfect timing.
So that extra requirement that you don't have loops anywhere
NOTE CONF
and there was another one, Right?
You do generics cool, Um, is advanced stuff.
NOTE CONF
You can write it.
It'll work using loops.
NOTE CONF
I just want you to think back to your stuff
from previous years and work out how you might do
NOTE CONF
it by taking loops out.
OK, and if you can't don't worry about it.
NOTE CONF
That's fine.
Make it work and get not quite full marks.
NOTE CONF
Yep, question about Oh yes, I haven't answered the percentages
question yet.
NOTE CONF
I will.
Yeah, so in But to clarify if the original input
NOTE CONF
string is 10 characters and the final output string is
20 characters, that's 100% increase.
NOTE CONF
If the original input the whole original input string, including
the semicolon including everything is five and the output is
NOTE CONF
15, that's a 300% increase.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Oh, no.
Now I see where the confusion is coming from.
NOTE CONF
Alright, So maybe I should change it from percentage increase
to times increase and then we could just keep ourselves
NOTE CONF
out of trouble, cos then if the second one was
300%.
NOTE CONF
The first one should be 200%.
And if the first one's 100% then the second one
NOTE CONF
is what?
Alright, Yeah, Yeah, I just chose really bad wording.
NOTE CONF
I'll clarify that by the time.
Um well, we're going home because no one had too
NOTE CONF
much YouTube or whatever he's doing on the back there.
And, uh, once I get him settled, then, uh, I'll
NOTE CONF
write up that clarification, but maybe I'll just switch to
two times so we don't have to worry about the
NOTE CONF
percentage thing.
But again, anyone who's submitted already, you know, we'll generously
NOTE CONF
interpret what you've done based on what we've said so
far.
NOTE CONF
Thank you for submitting early.
You can always resubmit if you want.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
Oh, no.
I said OK.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So can we have this glasses?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you want, you can nest all your glasses and
NOTE CONF
do whatever you want, as long as it compiles with
my line and runs with my line.
NOTE CONF
You're good to go.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
Just 39.
Can I ask you another question?
NOTE CONF
Um, because, um throughout the assignments, are you working towards,
like, the work going over or out.
NOTE CONF
Because then I will do my like, implementing correctly.
But now I was just, like, focusing on the first
NOTE CONF
assignment.
So I made like, uh, I, like, get the whole
NOTE CONF
story and kind of and then afterwards, the recursion on
it and check it one by one the first time
NOTE CONF
that mess about that.
But I know if I say the third one, I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna start from scratch again.
Just three here.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so I don't totally understand.
So no, uh, yeah, I don't remember that.
NOTE CONF
Just have done the easiest part to know then.
Ok, now the next time for me, take the lock.
NOTE CONF
Code provided and just Oh, OK, fair enough.
Ok, I know.
NOTE CONF
OK, right away.
Up to three.
NOTE CONF
Right, Three.
First I'm taking it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
What?
NOTE CONF
I think she was, uh, the country was one of
them.
NOTE CONF
Like we can take this.
Yes, I was.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So, bye.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna just stop staying.
Hello?
NOTE CONF
All right.
Sorry I fucking out of it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, all that the problem.
Yeah, Yeah.
NOTE CONF
What?
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
F.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
NOTE CONF
Take your wings up, OK?
Yeah, yeah, yeah You say it's all I'm gonna I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna press on it for you.
Yeah, I like you.
NOTE CONF
Say, if you want, we'll set it up here.
Right here.
NOTE CONF
I'll keep it.
Uh uh.
NOTE CONF
I'll set it up.
Do you wanna come past, like this alone or you
NOTE CONF
have a shave Very morning here, if you want.
I'll see you in a second.
NOTE CONF
It's like a lung.
It's not that bad.
NOTE CONF
I reckon it's a good way to that one.
Yeah, I'll walk these one shot from last week.
NOTE CONF
Like, I just I don't know, I Why we a
R?
NOTE CONF
He's a good shooter, and people don't love him.
I've got forro, huh?
NOTE CONF
The ra the rib, uh, L that's set through.
That's leukaemia.
NOTE CONF
And I OK, I guess, uh, you're not early.
That move in I with this one, right?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
I trust you.
NOTE CONF
I don't trust you.
We you don't have anywhere else, right?
NOTE CONF
What is it?
Oh, wait.
NOTE CONF
Are we in the one next door?
No, it's this one because I walk into the other
NOTE CONF
one there, and it wasn't because we're in the one
next door or something.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Uh, one second.
NOTE CONF
No.
What?
NOTE CONF
I?
I don't fucking honestly I haven't been a multi like
NOTE CONF
what was the case?
That the old discussion, right?
NOTE CONF
All that?
No, this one's always good.
NOTE CONF
No main car or to say you came for if
want to come back after the summer break, what do
NOTE CONF
you reckon is gonna happen?
Simul championship?
NOTE CONF
I don't know if Ma and player are I can
get land on.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, You guys are looking strong, man.
Yeah, fucking a.
NOTE CONF
No.
We're gonna have to do something in Paris because they
NOTE CONF
that Red Bull, the championship and they call it improve
the call because they're spending all the money in the
NOTE CONF
pas and, uh, funding for they're getting too much from,
uh, that makes a good brain that works with Well,
NOTE CONF
they were telling the sponsors.
Oh, yeah, We're gonna let him go.
NOTE CONF
And they're like, Oh, if you let him go, we're
gonna come on.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, of course they will.
Yeah, he's kind of some in his position.
NOTE CONF
He's quite a small.
That's the thing.
NOTE CONF
Like, if you're not gonna race, what's the point?
Yeah, like if you're not gonna contend that you're just
NOTE CONF
gonna tarnish your name and your reputation, he's been not
quality in that race.
NOTE CONF
I live inside it for the last eight days.
No surprise to me.
NOTE CONF
I gave him a massage.
I feel like you could put Wilson in that car
NOTE CONF
and you'd still get better results.
Anyone in the car?
NOTE CONF
A better result?
Yeah, it would have been nice to see, like, Carlos
NOTE CONF
go there.
Yeah, honestly, I was thinking my vision.
NOTE CONF
I think you just L the opportunities with positive.
It was, like 9999 o'clock in the morning.
NOTE CONF
I just not you.
Uh, so he was, like shutting down the, uh, like
NOTE CONF
Audi and stuff for too long?
Yeah, he he fucked the ramp.
NOTE CONF
If you had fucked the ramp for too long, he
would have been.
NOTE CONF
I think he was waiting for a top seat, but
he was waiting to see what happened with Perez.
NOTE CONF
And if T was a kidney?
Yeah, you know, you fuck joking?
NOTE CONF
Oh, yes.
It only come in from two hours and two hours
NOTE CONF
of spot on.
Yeah, so?
NOTE CONF
Well, I said I I at your laptop.
Too cold.
NOTE CONF
Everyone's OK.
Joins up.
NOTE CONF
Mhm.
Yes, I'm an in one.
NOTE CONF
Notice it.
I've submitted it, but they haven't.
NOTE CONF
I wish you put the CV R also, uh, can
push it The one I told you it looks heavy.
NOTE CONF
Is this a well name place?
Yeah, the fucking hospital.
NOTE CONF
What if the Oh, it's the top of your Are
you the the The low being called a part?
NOTE CONF
They, um, the one I told you to come to.
Yeah, I know what are there, you know?
NOTE CONF
Have you go to management of the place?
Uh, is it Mary?
NOTE CONF
Is that good?
I don't really married, but like, I have a few.
NOTE CONF
I've done a couple, um observes and they're all fucking
They treat patients just like numbers.
NOTE CONF
And they, um yeah, X-ray everyone.
Yeah, diet to like the visit.
NOTE CONF
And I it's It's our first visit.
No.
NOTE CONF
OK, yeah.
That x-ray for second visit.
NOTE CONF
My discussion about x-ray third visit was Yeah, he said
he does it after that.
NOTE CONF
He does it.
That's the pretty chosen just too.
NOTE CONF
I know you.
I get one.
NOTE CONF
Unfortunately, that's all I need.
Where did you get?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Yeah, it's That's home.
You got it.
NOTE CONF
Power C I four hours, four hours and 30 minutes.
You have a um Oh, take king away One, is
NOTE CONF
that correct?
You make it hit a bit bigger.
NOTE CONF
I don't see you know before.
I need to press anything here to see your song.
NOTE CONF
It sounds ridiculous.
It's almost Do I know?
NOTE CONF